little Kim shades Nicki Minaj right to
eat teeth Kanye breaks down at the Louis
Vuitton Fashion Show as he and wife Kim
Kardashian return to Paris for the first
time since the robbery everyone I'm dead
II direct oh this is the daily Denny and
today we got tea we got shade and we got
some tears let's start with Kanye West
who was overcome with a bit of emotion
today after his pal designer Virgil a
blow debuted his first collection as
Louie Vuitton menswear designer during
Paris Fashion Week now watch what
happens after the models took their
final march down the runway
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I had to play that out because I think I
love vulnerable Kanye you guys you know
when most designers end their shows with
a simple bow or a wave
Virgil gave us that amazing crying bro
hug with his longtime collaborator and
fellow shy town kid I think it's safe to
say they aren't just crying over pretty
close
Virgil started as an intern at Fendi in
2009 alongside Kanye they became
artistic collaborators which later led
to Virgil launching his high-end
streetwear brand off-white and now he's
the first person of African descent to
leave Louis Vuitton's menswear line so
it's a moment y'all also treating on
Virgil in the front row was mrs. West
herself Kim Kardashian and sister Kylie
Jenner with baby daddy Travis Scott and
Kim turned it all the way out in a blue
shirt dress from Virgil's collection and
paired the look with oversized
sunglasses black biker shorts and
strappy deals now the trip to Paris
Fashion Week marks the first time Kim
has been in the City of Lights since her
traumatic robbery in October 2016 Kim
later tweeted Thank You Paris for the
emotional trip back I couldn't have come
for a better reason meanwhile Kim's
sister Khloe and her man Tristan
Thompson seemed to be going strong the
new parents were back in LA and have
been spotted out and about recently on
Wednesday they left two months old true
at home for lunch at Joey restaurant
both going for a more casual look now a
source tells us that Kardashian's have
chosen to forgive and forget the
cheating scandal and aren't giving
Tristan a second chance and so far it's
working the couple has been pretty
inseparable since they got back to
California and thankfully for the fam
that means quality time with Chloe and
their new niece how excited are you that
Chloe is now back in LA that's so nice
to have her back oh I'm so excited it
was they came back on Sunday and I just
piled the kids in the car and took them
over to go meet their cousin true and it
was a love fest I mean it's so much fun
I feel like stormy and Chicago have so
many photo shoots together and we just
text the pictures to Chloe
of them like sitting on the couch and
we're like where you at true we're
waiting for you
so now that she could be in the mix it's
gonna be so much fun so a fam the family
is back together well actually no with
the exception of older sister Courtney
guys Courtney is out there getting her
groove back with younger boyfriend yonas
Benjamin the couple ditched LA and is
heating up Rome Italy for a little
romantic getaway they touched down on
Tuesday and Court flaunted those killer
abs of hers as you can tell and later
they visited trevi fountain to make a
wish together
I can't clearly the cuties are having a
blast and according to Courtney's
instant stories it's her first time in
Rome one of their first stops sipping on
some coffee at a cafe okay I need to
know from you guys
who was your favorite Kardashian couple
Kim and Kanye Chloe and Tristan or
Courtney and yonas let me know in the
comment section but you know it's not
all love at least not for little Kim
looks like her years long feud with
Nicki Minaj is still going strong
watch this subtle diss when our Katy
Kraus asked little Kim about raps to
rainy rap Queens at Paris Hilton bye boo
whose official launch party last night
you are one of the og women rappers I
grew up listening to you what do you
make of cardi B and Nicki Minaj party is
that girl I don't know the other one
party is my girl and so I'm so excited
for my girl cardi I can't wait for her
to have the baby I love you Karthik did
you hear that she says she don't know
the other one clearly a line in the sand
has been drawn and I've been cracking up
about this all day because of course
little Kim knows Nicki the two have
taken thinly veiled shots at each other
through their records over the years you
guys remember when little Kim dropped
Black Friday an obvious play on Nicki's
P Friday well there she called Minaj a
little Kim clone and wannabe that's for
who Kim is on good terms with the rapper
told us that she's still good friends
with hurt Lady Marmalade squad so what
would it take for the ladies to reunite
17 years later Kim says one phone call
don't take one phone call and scheduling
because we're all still really good
friends we still love each other all of
us that
you know a lot of times when you have
success in a group board with a record a
lot of times the girls aren't like
speaking or they either you know ones
like in contact with each other where we
always all of us always speak well let's
make it happen ladies Missy I'm talking
to you you can get them back together
I'll be waiting for that but in the mean
time I will be back tomorrow with new
music Friday including Demi Lovato's new
song sober which is apparently about her
recent relapse I got that for you guys
and a whole lot more tomorrow so I'll
see you then